these are very very serious allegations
about a thousand cases involving up to
200 deaths presumably their allegations
you refute very strongly well I think we
all have to remember that it's very easy
to make allegations it's quite a
different matter to investigate them and
to prove that those allegations have got
substance I think as far as the Army's
record is concerned in Iraq and
Afghanistan and and elsewhere in the
past and I think in the future where
there are allegations we take them
seriously and we investigate and when
there is substance we bring people to
due process and we've seen that with
this small number of cases that have
come to light with regard to iraq in the
past the baha mousa case was the most
obvious one where a man died most
shamefully in our custody and it led to
a court-martial but I think these
allegations they're so widespread
there's so many of them that I'm
absolutely honest I question the
motivation slightly of those behind
these and really what they're trying to
do there are so many allegations here I
think they're going to find it very hard
to substantiate them and I think this is
a very sad episode hmm but do you think
I mean it would be a huge embarrassment
wounded if for the UK if they end up
before the International Criminal Court
you say you you questioned some of the
motivation perhaps behind the
allegations but if it does end up before
the ICC it just doesn't look good for
the UK well of course it doesn't look
good for the UK we would look far worse
for the UK if a substantial number of
these allegations were substantiated and
found to be true but well you can call
me guilty of wishful thinking if you
like but I know the British Army and
British soldiers pretty well this is not
a common characteristic of them yes you
will occasionally get people who do the
wrong thing and where those allegations
are made and we investigate and we find
that wrong things have been done we put
due process against those people but
some to suggest that this was a systemic
widespread almost a matter of policy I
find that very hard
understand very hard to accept and I
would be very very surprised if a case
held up in somewhere like the ICC and
presumably one of the allegations you
can kick out right now the the
allegations contained within the numbers
there that knowledge of this system as
the allegation is went right to the top
you're at the top for a while well
indeed it didn't go right to the top I'm
not even Terry sure what I've said
already that these things actually took
place it is very easy to make
allegations it's a very different thing
to investigate and substantiate them the
suggestion that I've read in The
Independent this morning that the
Secretary of State the Minister of State
for the armed forces a senior general
are all new of these things or could
have been expected to know these things
I mean that's an amazing set of
allegations to make and as I say I don't
think that they will be substantial
they'll be provable yes there will be
the odd individual case and where that
they wear that case is discovered then
due process will be applied to those
people that's what we always do and
that's the right thing to do and are you
satisfied then that within the UK itself
we are investigating any allegations
thoroughly enough and and speedily
enough the for integrity pointed out the
Iraq historic abuse tribunal that's not
reporting till 2016 well the chilcot
enquiry isn't reporting on a great rush
of speed either I think these things do
take too long but in the case these
allegations of brutality and wrongdoing
they've only just been made now in this
dossier that's gone to the ICC so they
must be investigated and looked at as I
said several times this morning it's one
thing to make allegations it's quite
another thing to be able to prove them
and again I said maybe I'm guilty of
wishful thinking but I don't believe
it's in the character of the British
soldier I don't think it's in the
character the British people to engage
in widespread brutality of this nature i
think it's a it's most unfortunate set
of allegations and let's wait and see
how this plays out but I'm fairly
optimistic I'm very optimistic that
these allegations will not be proven